nous sommes en retournant toutefois mon
pote merci d'être avec nous les cherry
et je me demande si on va pas tout
filmer ce qui se passe pendant les pubs
parce qu'il faut que vous disent quelque
chose on est en direct il s'est passé
quelque chose sur ce plateau
il ya un instant juste sur moi ce qu'on
peut faire un plan sur quelqu'un
jean luc est ce que vous pouvez
expliquer ce qui s'est passé on avait on
a un arc et des flèches et donc c'est
franchement c'est pas de moi non jean
luc hees lui que c'est ce qui s'est
passé c'est que bah c'est la faute des
dirigeants de des huit avant tout parce
que s'il n'avait pas fait rumeurs games
mais plutôt la petite maison dans la
prairie on n'en serait pas là ça n'a pas
bien c'est donc il s'est dit tiens est
ce que quelqu'un pourrait mettre une
bouteille sur sa tête
oui évidemment il y en a un qui accepte
et ça tu comprends pas le projet les
images on a les images
regardez ça c'était alors c'était tout à
l'heure j'étais garde instaurant
regarder et donc voila vous jolie donc
ça mais ça aurait pu s'arrêter là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vers yard n'avait rien à leur goût à la
douma et je voulais pas couché le nom
on est en train de comprendre qu'il
voulait lui viser la gueule des picards
et comme il est une bouteille celle avec
ses présences et que cela dit on va
faire plus fort je vais faire tomber la
bouteille qui est pas sur ta tête
pascal et plus bouté sur sa tête et ce
qui devait arriver confiance et ils
doivent viser le front des fonds il est
content en plus à regarder et ne le
faites pas si vous ne le faites pas que
ça va mon corps mon douzième corps mais
ça moi aussi
il est bon camarade parce que il est bon
camarade y prend la flèche dans la
gueule j'étais à côté il se tenait il
avait mal et au lieu de se plaindre il a
fait quelques lycées relevé quand même
comment tu as fait pour toucher la
bouteille c'est ça la france de jean-mi
c'est pour ça qu'on aime
[Musique]